after a two-hour chase Romanian border
police have seized two thousand packets
of Ukrainian cigarettes but it's not
much of a catch the pursuit began in
Ukraine and continued through the
Romanian forest before the smugglers
finally cut their losses and fled
empty-handed it's just a regular night
in the region between the two countries
Esther looked on our model smuggling is
commonplace here the smugglers took
advantage of the darkness and the dense
forest to get away antonette exceed that
on accident but we stay close and we try
to identify them identification or
implicit she Lori
half an hour later on the other side of
the mountain the police pick up one of
the two men believed to have been in the
forest he lives in a village on the
Romanian border the whole area is
notorious for smuggling activity
knocking off I'd it wasn't me I bet it
was a Dior kichi but I wasn't with him
this time it wasn't me well teacher that
awful widget and all hey what were you
doing in the forest at this hour nobody
goes to cut down wood at this time of
night and comes back empty-handed but
the sniffer dog leaves no doubt that the
young man was one of the two carrying
the cigarettes the other one got away
using infrared cameras financed by the
european union officials watch over the
border by the eastern carpathian
mountains the mountains like the border
river the tisa are becoming increasingly
popular smuggling routes and those doing
the smuggling have even started using
divers and hang gliders to ensure the
safe passage of their goods into Romania
their activities cost European Union
countries an estimated ten billion euros
in lost tax revenue so the investment in
surveillance equipment quickly pays off
tolleson we have two of these devices
for 39 km/h we can see as far as five
kilometers they're really helpful
because most smuggling activity takes
place at night outfit but the infrared
cameras can't be used everywhere
particularly tough for the border police
are the dense forest areas which
smugglers know like the backs of their
hands many a part of the Ukrainian
minority in Romania and have relations
on the other side of the border
also the chant effective we are
definitely understaffed and we don't
have the situation under control we
don't even know when and where they will
appear they're really well organized and
even sent people ahead to cross the
border without any goods Martha salada
zonnos what time are we talking about
big sums of money I can't begin to guess
how much is turned over here alone we
head to the Romanian district capital of
sigur to marmot CA buying smuggled goods
here is not hard dozens of people sell
the cigarettes in the border town we
film a transaction using a hidden camera
cigarettes cigarettes what are you
selling how much for two packs two for
twelve lay so two years 60
they cost less than half the price of
legally sold cigarettes in Western
Europe a pack is six times more
expensive even when smuggled goods are
discovered not much happens because most
of them are produced illegally in China
Russia and Ukraine the brands are either
forged or simply made up we show the two
packets we bought in the district
capital to the border police at us on
this competitor the cello my motherland
and activate that silly they conned
every brand has a codename team but I ok
we know from tapped phone calls that red
packets like this one follow Solano meet
the core known as red paprika Stefan
each economy vice Trudeau shows a no me
hago casado dough so the authorities are
doing what they can to stop the
smuggling and that includes tapping
suspected smugglers phones
listen up I need a big delivery of red
paprika's bring them over and you can
earn twenty two hundred euros in a
single night the EU is planning to take
further action and to issue every packet
of cigarettes with an inspection tank
that would make it possible to trace the
path of goods from production to sale
but the Romanian police officers are not
convinced they expect to be spending
their nights chasing those involved in
one of Europe's most profitable
smuggling businesses for some time to
come